et nous avons également dès lors que
nous avons pu identifier
qu'il y avait une interrogation
stratégiques ce qui vous l'admettrez a
été exprimée de manière extrêmement
tardive puisque cela remonte à l'été
2000 21 tout le reste relevant de
coupures de presse de rumeurs mais en
aucun cas des changes entre partenaires
cependant engagé dans un contrat
important dans un partenariat
stratégique important donc nous nous
n'avons pas été dans l'évitement puisque
je vous ai indiqué les dispositions que
nous avions prises les tentatives de
dialogue que nous avions établi au cours
de l'été le fait que nous avions demandé
finalement à l'un de nos meilleurs
experts de se rendre en australie pour
avoir au meilleur niveau cet échange
avec les autorités australiennes sur au
fond l'adaptation ou
l'adéquation entre une analyse sur
l'environnement stratégique d'une part
et les moyens
fournis par ce programme de sous-marins
d'autre part donc non nous n'avons pas
été dans l'évitement et nous avons été
dans l'action
[Musique]